Hello Yakushi-sama, the cosmetics are already ready
.  We have prepared a cream type that blends easily into the skin. It
also has a sunscreen effect
.
[Music]
You can do something like that to prevent sunburn.
The reason for this is that the sunlight contains waves of various lengths, which can be seen by the
human eye 24
times
.
So if you do
something else, you should be able to have a sufficiently white skin.
Well,
the finish is this loose powder.
A finish powder that gives off a glittering feeling like fresh snow shining in the morning sun
.
It contains ingredients
If you keep taking care of it,
you can have the skin you want without
whitening.